[Music]  hey mama  about what you asked me to bring a  lifesaver we don't get lunch till 5:00  he'll yeah no you don't I brought what  she needs to eat sorry pumpkin but  there's my best food has no place in  pageantry especially right before you  walk out on stage  this is a mom and Jean has no business  in the pageant world it's a pageant  world it's classy she's just kind of  trashy  I've been called white trash so many  times but you know was trashy to me is  people talking about me in front of my  daughter  and also talking John at an  anti-bullying charity event  she just doesn't even fit in this world  damn and her little friends are getting  on my nerves I mean I let Hannah have  her little friends get on my nerves at  her and really get to me but they are  baby  buddy-buddy philosophy let you hate us  be a motivate us and also do have  friends here too lacy I'm a person  they're here  I'm in allowing you alright I am proud  of you well under yours I probably  [Music]